The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Today, we're
doing electric power
systems, sort of as they are,
and as they have been.
In 2010, electric power
systems were about 40%--
I'm going to have to stand
here and use the keyboard--
about 40% of primary energy, and
40% of CO2 emissions, roughly.
Most electricity goes to
residential and commercial
sectors and supplies about
46% of the energy they use.
What I want to do
today is to talk
about the essential
features of these systems.
I'm guessing most of you haven't
had a course in power systems
since MIT doesn't teach a
course in power systems,
really, and talk a little bit
about the regulatory regime.
Monday we'll look
forward, what are
some of the challenges, what are
some of the opportunities, what
are some of the policy issues?
So let's talk about
the power system.
The one thing you really
do have to keep in mind
is despite all of the
interest in storage,
and everybody talks about
storage of electricity.
As a practical
matter, you simply
can't store electricity in
bulk at a reasonable cost.
You can pump water uphill and
use pumped hydro, and that's
pretty good, that's
pretty efficient,
it's very hard to build
new pump hydro sites.
There's one in New England.
There are no plans
for any others.
And as we'll see next
time, the value of storage
goes up over time.
You can also pump
air underground.
And there are like two
of those in the world.
And there's a lot of
research into batteries,
but so far nothing looks cheap.
So at the moment, the
system operates effectively
without storage.
And this matters
because demand varies
over time in ways that
are perfectly predictable.
Here's some seasonal variation.
This is a forecast
for New England.
And you'll see that as it says,
their week 8 is late July.
Week 8 was forecast
to be the peak.
And week 32, which is that
sort of secondary peak
is early January.
Most American systems
now look like that.
They peak in the summertime,
that's air conditioning.
There's also a good
deal of variation.
So you have to follow that load.
You have to follow that
variation in demand.
But hour-by-hour, there's
a lot of variation.
Does the laser work?
No.
OK, how long are my arms?
That sort of an
interesting-- that's what?
Last week for New England.
And you'll see first of all
that the load in this relatively
uneventful April week varied
within a day between 9,000
and just about 16,000 megawatts.
That's fairly substantial.
You see April 2nd was a Monday.
So you can see demand is
higher during the week
than the last two
which are the weekends.
You'll also see the
distinctive feature.
There's sort of a morning peak
and an evening peak most days.
The evening peak, again focus
on the actual load, the blue.
The evening peak is the higher.
And the minimum occurs in
the middle of the night,
not too surprisingly.
But the system
has to track that.
The system has to track that.
The other thing you will see
in terms of predictability,
forecast load, I'm not sure
how far ahead that forecast is.
But DA is Day Ahead.
So the New England system
operates with a market.
And there's a real
time clearing,
which there has to
be because you have
to follow it second-to-second.
But there's also a
day ahead market.
So the DA gives you in effect
the day ahead forecast.
And you will see the
difference between the green
and the blue is usually
small but not trivial, not 0.
What else to say?
Any comments or
questions so far on this.
Yeah, Jacob.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
it's got to be made up.
The question is,
that's a day ahead.
Some of this is going to be--
the actual load tended
to be above the day
ahead which suggests--
well, if this were
the summertime,
I'd say this suggests warmer
than expected, which is
sort of what it was that week.
You get better at forecasting
the weather as you get closer.
So an hour or two ahead.
It's not like, oh, my God, right
now we've got to make a change.
But you may have a few hours
warning that it's warmer
than we thought.
So we really have
to ramp stuff up.
But yeah, something has
to follow that load.
It could be hydro.
It could be gas turbines.
It's not going to
be big coal plants
because as I'll
come to in a minute,
following load with big coal
plants is very expensive.
There's a lot of
stuff you get hot.
There's a lot of stuff spinning.
And to let that cool
off and/or slow down
and then bring it back
wastes a lot of energy.
So you want things that
are quick that don't
have a lot of rotating mass.
And that don't
have a lot of stuff
that you have to heat and cool,
I have to heat and then reheat.
Anything else?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Why
is there 10,000 what?
AUDIENCE: Megawatts [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, it could.
What are these people doing?
I don't know.
This is you guys
working late, I guess.
You've got me.
Some of that traditionally
would be industrial load,
like if you're running
a factory three shifts.
There's not that much
of that in New England.
Some of it may be HVAC in
some buildings consuming
electricity, fans running,
various kinds of machinery.
There are also these
vampire load devices,
when you have almost anything
plugged in, even if it's
turned off, it sucks power.
So those loads have gone up.
I have never really seen an
analysis of 3:00 AM load.
But you're right.
Your consumption probably
goes a lot lower.
You're within day variation
is probably greater than that.
And I'm trying to think
about the apartment building
where I live and what goes
on at 3:00 in the morning.
And about all that's going
on is in a warm period
like this there may be some AC
usage, although ours wasn't on.
So I don't know.
And you know, you've
got appliances
running all night long,
refrigerators and such.
But I don't know.
Anything else?
Yeah, Jacqueline.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: The
forecast is presumably--
and I should have checked
before I put this up.
The forecast is presumably
farther back in time than day
ahead.
The forecast is a forecast.
This would be the
regional authority.
And I'll talk about
them a bit later.
The regional authorities
guess maybe a week ahead
or two weeks ahead.
Day ahead clear demand,
that's a market.
People bid to supply.
There's demand.
Well, it clears at a price.
We'll come to price later.
But that is a market.
That's a market outcome.
That's a forecast outcome.
And I just don't know
how far in advance.
But it's clearly by the regional
authority that runs the system.
An actual load is what
actually happened when you
turned on your computer, so OK.
Short term variation, minute to
minute, the frequency, right?
Everything assumes, all
your equipment assumes,
your appliances
assume that you'll
be getting electricity that
vary 60 cycles a second.
That frequency has
to be maintained.
And it's mainly maintained
by sort of automatic control
at designated units.
But when you get big
changes like that,
governors aren't going to do it.
And you will need to
bring units on and off.
So let me talk about
technology mix.
So we mentioned a little
earlier that you have fast
responding generating
units, turbines say,
or diesels to respond to
short term variations in load.
But even if you could
forecast the load,
you would want units like that.
And as I mentioned, it's
expensive to vary the output
from what are called base
load units, nuclear power
plants, big coal plants.
But not only that, when
you run them flat out,
they have very low running
cost, nuclear virtually 0,
coal pretty low.
You can buy turbines or diesels.
But they're very expensive
to build these big units.
The little units, peaking
units or intermediate units,
but let me just
assume two kinds,
think coal plants
and gas turbines,
they're cheap to
build, but they're
expensive to run, relatively
on today's prices.
So you would want
since load varies,
you're not going to run your
whole fleet all the time,
right?
If we didn't have
those variations,
if demand were constant,
you just build,
well, but for
environmental issues
you just build
cheap coal plants,
cheap nuclear plants if you
could find one, combined cycle
plants and run
them all the time.
But since the load
varies, you know
that you're not going to run
your plants all the time.
So what do you do?
If you look, Imagine two
plants of the same capacity.
One is, I call it a peaker,
but let it be a gas turbine.
And the other is a baseload,
let it be a coal plant.
They don't tend to have
the same capacities,
but for the sake of
argument, suppose they do.
You ask, what's the
total cost of this plant?
The more hours you
run it, the larger
will be the fuel cost as a
component of total cost, right?
So the total cost
consists of the cost
of building the thing,
basically taken down
to say a per day cost
or a per year cost.
And then the slope is the
marginal cost of running it.
So the height gives
you the total cost.
If you're going to
run all year long,
then the base load plant
is the plant to build.
Because way out here, the
fact that the fuel is cheap
makes up for the capital cost.
But if you're only going
to run it a little bit
but you have to
have it, then you
want to build a peaker, right?
Is that notion clear?
The fact that there's
output variation
means you want to have
plants of multiple types.
If you can get a base
load plant to run
almost all the time,
or all the time, then
you're in great shape.
But if you have to
have plants that
run only a little bit,
only a few hours per year,
then you've got to
have some of these.
And you've always got that mix.
We're going to talk about
wind and solar next time.
They don't quite fit
either of these categories,
if you think about
it for a minute.
But if that's clear,
then let's look at this.
The red curve is what's
called a low duration curve.
And it's the actual curve,
because I happen to find it.
It's the actual curve for--
it's probably England and Wales.
It says Great Britain, for 2007.
What a low duration
curve is, you
look at how much electricity
was consumed hour-by-hour.
And you basically convert those
to a graph putting the hour
with the highest
consumption here, then
the second highest there.
You basically stack it up.
So out here at 100%, you have
the consumption, the demand,
and it's expressed as
a percentage of peak
to keep life simple, the
percentage of peak demand
at the lowest hour of the
year, presumably at 3 o'clock
in the morning on
some day that was
neither hot nor cold
so nobody needed
to run anything, any HVAC.
And it was a holiday, so there
was no industrial work going
on, or whatever.
So if you go back to this
picture, this picture says,
if you're going to run a plant
fewer than H star hours a year,
you're going to want to peak.
It's going to have to be a peak.
It should be a peaker
rather than a baseload.
Come to this picture, and
you say, OK, let's suppose--
just because it
fits the picture--
that if there are
8,760 hours in a year,
this is like 42
gallons in a barrel,
another one of those
numbers you have to have.
8,760 hours in a year,
let's see if I can do this.
If you build baseload
capacity up to this line,
you know that it will be
running at least that fraction
of hours.
You'll have to cut
it down somewhat
in the really low hours.
But if you build that
much baseload capacity,
it will run for at
least this many hours.
Because demand exceeds that
capacity for that fraction
of the year, right?
So we're asking,
you decide what you
want to build in terms
of baseload capacity
as a fraction of the peak.
Read across to the
curve and come down
and you get the fraction of
hours of the year when demand
is at least that high, right?
So we've normalized
the low duration curve
so the peak is 100.
We also normalized time,
which is kind of awkward
so that 8,760 hours equals 100.
So we can do percentages.
So again, this is just stylized.
But if H star over
8,760 is here,
then that says you build half
baseload capacity and half
peaker capacity, right?
The peakers are only
going to come into play
when demand is above--
and this is where
I need the laser--
is above that 50% point.
That's an artifact.
This is stylized 50%.
It has no particular
significance in life.
It just works out
in this picture.
So you'd build 1/2 peaker
capacity and 1/2 base load.
The peak units would be on for
less than H star hours a year,
or less than this fraction
of hours per year.
So it makes some sense.
You see why you need the mix.
And this is just
mechanical to say,
if I know where the breakpoint
is, then I've got to say,
what fraction of the year.
I've got to use the
low duration curve
to go from the break
point where I decide
between the different
technologies, the base
load and the peaker
in this case,
and to get a capacity mix out
of that, for what fraction
of the year, blah, blah, blah.
OK, I know I want to build
baseload plants that will
run at least this fraction.
We'll run at least this
fraction of the year.
I want peakers
that will run less.
The load duration curve
translates that into capacity,
OK.
Detail is not critical,
concept pretty critical.
Questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I'd
have to use them both, right?
I'd have to go back
and say, OK, what
are the characteristics
of these technologies?
Where's the breakpoint?
Where is the breakpoint?
And then what I
would do in fact,
if I'm doing this, if
I'm centrally planning
and I'm not a market, if I'm
centrally planning I would A,
allow for reserve margin.
So I wouldn't build
just capacity.
And I would allow for the fact
that I don't know the load
duration curve exactly.
So I'd do a little
stochastic work here.
I'd say, if the curve
varies up and down by 20%,
what do I need to be sure?
And I'd work out a somewhat
more complicated problem.
What I gave you was, well, if
I've only got two technologies
and the slate is
clean, then I know
how to choose based on how
long the plant is going to run.
And using this curve, I can
go from how long the plant is
going to run to how
much of it I need,
based on how many
hours demand will
be above and below
certain levels, right?
So yeah, that's exactly what
this exercise in the very
simple case would do.
It would optimize the fleet.
And you need both.
Even if you don't have to worry
about quick response, which
is not present in this
picture, you'd need both, OK.
In fact, in real systems you
have multiple technologies.
And this is a very strange
graph, but it makes that point.
This shows in 2008
supposedly ranked vertically
by marginal cost
and horizontally
by capacity, all the plants
in the lower 48 states.
And so it gives you
sort of a supply curve.
The lower 48 states are
not a single market.
So it's a funny kind
of supply curve.
But it gives you the sense.
It shows hydro there in the
far left, which essentially, it
has only an opportunity
cost of running, right?
If you let the water out now,
you don't have it tomorrow.
So there's a little bit
of an opportunity cost.
But out of pocket is 0.
And then you've got nukes, which
have a very low running cost.
And then you've got this mixture
of coal and gas and others.
And then finally, up here
that vertical portion,
that's the oh, my God,
start the diesels portion.
That's the very hot summer day
when very inefficient, very
dirty diesels that
are kept around
to run for only a few
hours a year get fired up.
So there are really
expensive units
that you keep on hand,
even though they're
expensive to run
because you've got them.
And on a hot summer
day, you may need them.
So in fact, that two
technology picture
that I gave you is too simple
because you'd want to build
a more complicated mixture.
But you need a mixture, OK.
Comments, yeah, Scott.
AUDIENCE: So by
capacity, does it mean
what capacity you turn it on?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: No,
it means, this tells you
the total hydro capacity.
This is the total nuclear
capacity, this distance.
So it's giving you a sense
of how much you can get
at different marginal costs.
So it is a supply
curve in that sense
if they were all in the same
market dot, dot, dot, dot,
yeah, OK.
OK, what's the grid look like?
You can have multiple
generating plants
in any particular region.
But you really
can't economically
have multiple
transmission systems
and multiple
distribution systems.
They are typically considered
natural monopolies.
What a natural monopoly
means is generally
defined as having more than
one of them would raise costs.
So if you think of the X's
in that subadditivity bullet
as basically electricity
supplied to houses,
so each component is
a house or a building,
rather than total kilowatt
hours, but a vector
of locations, then
subadditivity by that definition
means it's cheaper to supply.
You can't split the system
without raising costs.
The normal picture
you get for this
is, if the X's are scalars, then
it's just economies of scale.
So natural monopoly is
present in electricity.
It's present in
other areas as well.
Let's do a minute on why
there's a problem when
you have a natural monopoly.
What's the policy problem?
Why do we bother
to talk about it?
Alex, are you raising your hand?
Or no, you were not
raising your hand.
You were thinking about
raising your hand?
No, not even that.
OK, OK, we're back
in 1401 or 001.
Kierstan and then David.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
otherwise a natural monopoly
would release them to just
take as much as they could.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So what enables
it to take as much as it could?
AUDIENCE: No competition.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So you think
there would be no competition
and they'd make a lot of money.
But we like making a
lot of money, don't we?
Consumers don't.
So there'd be a welfare loss.
David?
AUDIENCE: I mean, yeah, they
could just charge as much
up to the point where it would
be profitable for another firm
to enter.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I mean,
it's actually interesting.
We always assume in
these discussions
that competition isn't viable.
And cable television
is a standard example
of a natural monopoly, local
cable television distribution.
But there are a number
of places where there
are competing cable systems.
And that's wasteful, but it may
be less wasteful than having
really high prices--
welfare loss because
of high prices.
AUDIENCE: They can
also under supply.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
that's the same story, right?
You raise the price.
You supply less.
I can't draw it.
You might like to end
up at some point like A,
and in fact, what a monopoly
in this situation might do
is produce 1/2 that where
the production would B,
but the price would be
notably higher than at A.
AUDIENCE: That's good
for the environment.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: What?
AUDIENCE: It's good for the
environment [INAUDIBLE],,
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Good for the environment.
So we should just
deregulate electricity
throughout because we'd
spent a lot of money.
Interesting point.
Anybody else, anything
else that could go wrong
in this situation?
OK, what about cost?
Let's think about human beings
running an organization.
And you have no competition.
And you're providing
a necessity.
And your brother-in-law
asks for a job.
You hire your
brother-in-law, right?
There's a cost problem.
We always draw these curves
like these come out of the sky.
And we march down cost curves.
In fact, these are determined
by organizational decisions.
And when you have a monopoly,
the pressure to actually do
unpleasant things like
firing people or not
hiring your brother-in-law,
those pressures are gone.
Not gone, they're diminished.
They're diminished.
So you expect high costs.
There's another
reason, and it's not
true for all natural monopolies.
But it's true for the ones that
we're mostly concerned about,
most of these things are
called public utilities.
Now, it's not true for
cable television yet.
Electricity used to
be a luxury good.
Telephones used to
They're not anymore.
They're mostly
considered necessities.
And when you raise the price,
as Kierstan wanted them to do,
to raise the price to
pay for necessities,
you're basically taking money
out of poor people's pockets
and giving them to
rich shareholders.
So these are the problems that
people mostly worry about.
And that business about
triangles and rectangles,
let me just remind you.
For some reason let
this be marginal cost
equals average cost.
And this is the demand curve.
And this is, of course,
what you'd like, right?
You'd like production
at the point
where price equals
marginal cost.
And this is the price axis,
and this is the quantity axis.
The classic thing that
a monopoly might do
is to produce say,
QM, and charge PM.
And then the deadweight loss,
this triangle over here.
I'm hoping, I'm
reminding you, it's
the difference between what
people were willing to pay
and what it would have cost
to produce this output that's
not produced.
So that's a loss, right?
If you reduce output
from say Q star to QM,
you lose that triangle.
But suppose what
in fact, happens
is the monopolist is really
lazy and costs go up to PM.
Well, in that case, you
lose the rectangle too.
And in most reasonable
cases, the rectangles
are bigger than the triangles.
So that if I can't resist
hiring my brother-in-law,
neither can anybody else.
That could be much worse aside
from the rich/poor issue,
than the fact that
I'm pricing high, OK.
So these are things
you worry about.
What do you do about it?
Water supply is like this.
You could argue bus
service is like this.
Telephone distribution
is like this.
Electricity distribution
Electricity transmission
is like this.
Now, we're mostly about energy.
But it is a general problem.
What are some of the
solutions, right.
This difficulty,
a natural monopoly
arises across time and
space and industries.
And a variety of mechanisms
have been adopted.
What might you do?
So we could have a private firm,
and we could regulate it, OK?
Anything else, Brendan?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, that's not good.
What am I going to do?
If I can't have competition
as an economic matter.
I can split it.
You're saying
forced competition.
Well, what if I split it
and in fact, one of them
goes out of business?
See, the problem with this, if
you go back to this picture,
if I've got two
firms and they're
both on this cost
curve, the larger one
always has a cost advantage.
So you can imagine
competition working.
But you could also imagine the
larger firm drives the smaller
firm out just competing.
And nobody comes in because
they have a big cost
disadvantage if they come in.
So that's a tough one.
Most industries, that's
what you want to do.
And that's what's done.
But that's tough here.
Anything else?
Yeah, Max.
AUDIENCE: A government
run enterprise.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You
could have a government run
enterprise.
Let me drill down a
little bit on regulation.
How might you regulate?
Max.
AUDIENCE: Price floor.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
no, you actually probably
don't want to price floor.
Price ceiling maybe.
Oh, you want them to raise
prices to bring in entry?
Yeah, ooh, ooh, that could
be really expensive, right?
Remember, if you split,
you've raised costs.
And now you're going
to raise the price
to make sure that you can
survive with higher costs.
You get more companies in.
There actually have been
examples of competing
telephone systems historically.
I don't know of any
competing, I don't
know offhand of any competing
electric distribution systems.
There are competing
cable systems.
It's expensive, right?
I mean, you're duplicating.
You're duplicating.
So most people say, that's
triangles versus rectangles.
You're saying,
I'll tolerate, I'll
tolerate a higher cost
as long as they're not
making any money.
Well, I don't want to pay a
higher price, Max, I'm sorry.
I'm happy that they're
not making profits.
But what you're managing
to do is to raise the cost.
And that's the natural
monopoly problem.
That's the core of it.
If you get competition, then you
will have it at a higher cost.
And sometimes, if
you think about ways
that curve could look, sometimes
in fact, if that curve is
shallow enough, you'd be right.
Let's have a little competition,
the costs will go up,
but the incentives
will be stronger.
They will not hire
their brothers-in-law.
And yeah, the costs will be up.
But the pressure on
prices will overwhelm it.
Mostly that's not true.
I mean, telephone it might be.
Wireless, it surely is.
That's why we can have
competing wireless companies.
We have maybe three in Europe.
They tend to have more.
That's easy.
But wireline, that's tough.
Yeah, David.
AUDIENCE: So the
shareholders are
the people who are using
the services, do You know?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well, that
would be a cooperative model.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: That's
exactly the cooperative model.
And you do see it.
You do see it.
Let me just mention, there are
a number of different ways.
Those are the three
main alternatives.
There are a number
of different ways
to skin this one, to regulate.
And I'll just say a little bit,
not go into too much detail.
Regulation, so I've got
government ownership
at the top and
cooperatives at the bottom.
I didn't talk about
franchise bidding.
I think that will take us
a little too far afield.
But that's the bid for the
right to provide electricity.
Different kinds of
regulation, you could do--
the early streetcars and buses
and electric power systems
and cable systems were
regulated by cities.
And the city had
jurisdiction because they
needed to use the streets.
So yes, you can put
up your phone lines,
yes, you can run the streetcars.
But you need to comply
with certain restrictions.
I will talk about rate
of return regulation.
That's been the
dominant way electricity
has been regulated since
the early 20th century.
It's focused on profits.
And incentive
regulation is to try
to hold prices
constant for a while
to give incentives to cut cost.
I will cycle back to this.
I will cycle back.
But just to know that there
are a whole set of approaches
that have been used.
They all become political.
They involve decisions
made by people.
made by people
who are subject to voters,
typically, one way or another,
either government enterprise
or they are regulated
or the co-op members vote.
So one of the things you
want to do is as little
of this as possible.
So transmission
and distribution,
natural monopolies
pose a policy problem.
In terms of the
architecture, I don't know
why this is a blackboard talk.
But when I say that low voltage
distribution systems are
a tree, there will
be a substation
and feeders go out to serve
neighborhoods and houses
and so forth.
The transmission
system, if you look,
I'll show you a map
in a little bit.
But you might have
a generator here.
You might have city or
load here and load there
and another generator here.
The transmission
system will be a mesh.
It's a different architecture.
It means there are
multiple paths.
In the tree structure,
you'd have a substation.
And this would be a house.
There's only one path.
There are multiple paths,
well, in this case three
from this generator
to this load.
The reason for multiple paths
of course, is reliability.
The reason for a tree
structure is cost.
In some dense urban areas,
the distribution system
is a mesh because
the lines are short.
And you might as well.
But if you think of any rural
or suburban area, it's a tree.
The transmission system, I
have to say for most of us
it takes a little
getting used to.
You don't switch current, right?
If you do the analysis,
power from this generator
to this load goes
on all three paths,
depending on the
characteristics of the path.
You can change those
characteristics
with expensive technology.
But mostly it's passive.
That means-- well,
it means two things.
That means if I demand more
here, Demand goes up here,
and I increase generation
here, I could in fact
cause a problem on this
line because some power
will flow through it.
And if that line can't
handle it, I could run into,
it could overheat.
It could sag.
This is called loop flow.
When electricity over multiple
paths causes problems,
particularly let's say,
that's a national border.
So I can cause
congestion over here.
I can cause a problem
over here when I increase
demand and generation here.
Now, you might say,
well, can't we fix that?
The answer is a little bit.
We can fix that now
with power electronics.
We can change some of the
characteristics of these lines.
But it's expensive,
and it's not much done.
OK, so it's a strange system.
It's not intuitive,
not intuitive.
Question about the architecture
or about the problem?
OK, here's the picture.
Yeah, there are
about 170,000 miles
in the US of high voltage.
I think it's 200k,
200,000 volts,
230,000 volts is the
threshold for transmission.
You will note that
the country is
divided into three things
that are labeled interconnect.
Technical description,
the interconnects
are connected with
relatively low capacity,
direct current lines
in a couple of places.
Each interconnect is
basically one big machine.
Everything is turning
together, everything
is synchronized, all the
generators, all the frequency--
little variations, but not much.
It's easy to see why there's an
Eastern and a Western, right?
Because you've got
the Rocky Mountains,
relatively low
population density.
It didn't make a
lot of sense to try
to connect New York
and Los Angeles
in the same synchronized system.
It certainly didn't
50 years ago.
Probably doesn't now.
Why is Texas independent?
Why is Texas a
separate interconnect?
Why isn't Texas synchronized?
Oh, take a jump.
Take a shot.
AUDIENCE: Didn't want to.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
There was a political deal
made in the '30s.
It was a political deal
made in the '30s that
has the fiction but near truth
that electrons don't cross
the boundaries of this area.
Therefore what goes
on in here is not
subject to federal regulation
because it's wholly
within one state.
Does that make electrical sense?
No, Should it be obvious that
Texas and Louisiana should
be separate electrically?
No, but in the '30s, it was
part of getting a deal done.
Whenever you see
something like this,
do not assume it's
a technical reason.
Because it usually isn't.
I'll give you one
other example and then
I'll take your question.
Within the country there are
about 107 so-called balancing
areas.
Each balancing area
is a control center
that's responsible
for electrical flows
across its boundary, right?
It will have certain obligations
like not sending a lot out
or not bringing a lot in.
So there's one control,
there's one balancing area
in New England.
There's one balancing
area in New York.
There are eight balancing
areas in Arkansas.
That is not the answer to
any technical question,
OK, Brendan.
AUDIENCE: Because of this
system, do people in Texas
pay a higher, lower
cost for electricity?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Oh, I would say
trying to figure out
whether this system has
had any effect on Texas
costs is probably impossible.
Texas rates are reasonably low.
Texas burns a lot of coal.
Texas is big enough that the
reliability implications aren't
that great, right?
If you decided to make
Belmont, Massachusetts
separate from the rest of the
country with say one generating
plant if Belmont
has one, you would
expect reliability problems
just because if that plant goes
down, which it has
to occasionally,
the system goes down.
Texas is big enough that
hasn't been an issue.
Texas has a lot of renewables,
which is kind of a surprise.
But Texas has a
lot of wind power.
That's an issue, it is
also is a cost issue.
But I don't think
this has much to do
with the price of
electricity in Texas.
It's just a really
interesting oddity, and is
I hope always a cautionary flag.
When you see something
that looks like it's weird,
it's either a political deal or
a consequence of the tax system
is my rule of thumb.
And this is a deal.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So why
isn't all of Texas?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah,
it's a good question.
And I don't know.
I don't know.
You wonder why I say, I think
that's Amarillo up there,
that top dot.
And I do not know
why whoever made
the deal wrote off North Texas.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Same boundary, boundaries
haven't changed.
No, no, you don't want to
say that too close to Texas.
I mean, Texas is--
when I asked this question the
first year I taught the course,
the answer from a Texan
was, so we can secede.
I don't know why they wouldn't
take Amarillo with them.
And whoever that
second dot is, I
don't know who that is either.
I don't have an answer.
My guess is that actually
was an electrical response.
That part of Texas may have had
closer electrical connections
outside the state than inside.
And somebody said,
look, that would
be really stupid to kind of
reconfigure the transmission
system.
I'm guessing.
I don't know.
Anything else?
OK, all right, let me spend
most of the rest of the time
on sort of how we
got here and walk
through the regulatory history.
First, central generating
station, Thomas Edison,
New York, 59
customers, lighting.
And by the way, you think you
have a load variation problem
now with those New
England things,
think about when your
only product is lighting.
You shut the whole system
down in the daytime.
This is not a good way
to use your assets.
So one of the first
things they did
was push for
electric streetcars.
These early systems,
direct current systems
were regulated mostly by cities.
They were local.
They were direct current.
Direct current at
low voltage doesn't
travel very far efficiently.
And you don't want to put high
voltage into people's homes.
So we had a bunch
city-regulated systems
and then we had a bunch
of city-run systems.
So in 1900, as
far as I can tell,
the peak of municipal
systems, Belmont has one,
Los Angeles has one, they peaked
at 8% of generation in 1900.
As alternating current
came in, and the big thing
with alternating current is
you can change it's voltage
relatively easily.
So you can have high voltage
to send it long distances.
And then you can take it
down for use in homes.
So the transformer really makes
alternating current the winner.
Now, You can take
DC up and down.
But it's more expensive.
And you couldn't do
it for a long time.
So alternating current wins.
And as you begin to make
it technically possible
to go beyond a city--
if you're doing
direct current, you're
building a generating station,
you're serving a neighborhood.
We talked about
the London system
and how it stayed that
way for a long time.
That's how they grow up.
You build a generator
to serve a neighborhood.
And then maybe you go
to alternating current.
But technically, once you
can do higher voltages,
you can expand.
You can link up separate cities.
And that began to
happen after the turn
of the century and states took
over-regulation from cities.
The idea was we'd set up
these impartial commissions.
And these impartial
non-political public utility
commissions, not elected in most
states, not subject to removal
by the government,
independent commissions
was an invention that
started, I'm now forgetting,
I think Wisconsin in 1907.
And by 1920, everybody,
almost everybody had them.
Is anybody here from Nebraska?
OK, Nebraska doesn't have
a public utility commission
because no private
firm is selling
electricity in Nebraska.
It's all government and co-ops.
But everybody else has one.
The Europeans didn't do this.
What happened, the European
system started out like this.
It started out
local, began to grow
and became government
enterprises.
Why?
OK, you figure that's the answer
to an engineering question.
That is not the answer to
an engineering question.
The same electrons,
same technology,
similar densities in many areas.
Jacob, save me here.
AUDIENCE: Although they
may have provinces,
they're not as independent
government institutions
as they are in
the United States.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
that's true to some extent.
Although, take Germany.
Germany is and has been to
the extent that it was--
well, it wasn't democratic
for a long time.
But it began as a set
of independent countries
that became the [INAUDIBLE].
It became a federal system.
So when the government took
over the Berlin system,
it was the Berlin government.
It wasn't the
national government.
So not all of these government
enterprises were national.
But it's a good point.
The political
structures differed.
And the US was if
not unique, then
it stood out as having
this whole state structure.
It's just an
ideological difference.
An ideological difference.
The US had a strong preference
for private enterprise.
Europe had a less
strong preference.
It was a big debate in
the US through the '30s.
Should this stuff be government
or should it be private?
Private mostly won in the US.
Government mostly won in Europe.
You can make
arguments both ways.
I talked about various
solutions to natural monopolies.
The government
solution is, look,
there are no shareholders
trying to rape and pillage here.
We're just all trying
to serve the customers.
The private response
is, yes, and you're all
hiring your brother-in-laws.
The costs are high.
You have no stockholder
pressure to be efficient.
Costs will be too high.
That debate ran
for 30, 40 years.
It still goes on
in some quarters.
One side won in Europe.
One side won in the US.
OK, so far the
states, now the feds.
The federal government got
into electricity first in 1906
selling cheap surplus power
from irrigation projects.
It gave preference to
municipalities rather than
private buyers.
Why was it cheap, do you think?
Why was the power cheap
from irrigation projects?
OK, today is quirky
political explanations day.
In calculating the cost
of building something,
the government tends to
use its borrowing rate.
The cost of capital
to the government,
which has the power to tax is
lower than the cost of capital
to private firms that don't.
So all else equal,
the government
can produce power cheaper.
And if the main cost
is capital, which
it is for a hydro facility,
it could be a lot cheaper.
So the government says,
we're not making any money,
we will sell it cheaply.
But then you've got to
figure out who gets it.
And the decision was
municipal utilities.
During the run up to the '20s--
and that's an
amazing period if you
think about growth industries.
I just ran the numbers.
The growth in electric
power between 1900 and 1929
averaged 14% a year.
That's a boom.
That's a long boom.
That was fun.
It was fun except that these
guys were being regulated.
So their response was, we're
being regulated by states.
Let's have holding companies
that operate in multiple states
so we can kind of hide
the ball from regulators.
And it was used to
fuel stock speculation.
So they had a lot of fun.
They built these big
holding companies.
I'll come back to that.
The federal power
commission, now the FERC,
was formed in 1920 because
all navigable waterways
are federal.
It began to do some
regulation from 1935.
In 1935 in response to
these holding companies,
which really were
weird creatures.
And they were blamed for the
stock market crash of 1929.
You always need to
find a scapegoat.
So the scapegoat was
these utility companies.
They were broken.
They were broken up.
You had to operate in
one contiguous area.
You couldn't have a company
here and a company there
under the same umbrella.
Well, that really enforced what
was the vertically integrated
monopoly structure.
The same company would generate
the power, transmit the power,
and sell you the power.
In the '30s, one of
Roosevelt's initiatives
was to get power to rural
areas, one of his priorities.
The existing utilities
weren't interested in doing it
because it's expensive.
And their current
customers didn't
want to pay higher prices so
the farmer in the next county
can get power.
What the federal remedy was,
we'll enable a set of co-ops.
And we'll sell them cheap
power from federal facilities.
That's what was done.
TVA is the most
visible sort of we'll
generate from federal
facilities and sell cheap.
But we did a bunch of it.
And in 1950 when it peaked,
the federal government
generated 12% of
us electricity, OK.
So far so good?
That's the history.
State regulation-- so the
bulk of the regulatory effort
from 1907, particularly
after 1935, that's PUHCA,
always pronounced puka.
State regulators required
just and reasonable rates.
This was rate of
return regulation.
They would set
prices in principle
so that the utility would just
earn a fair rate of return.
You've got to have some profits.
What's a fair profit?
Well, we know what your
cost of capital is.
We'll figure out what that is.
And we'll set the rates
so you just earn that.
So what might go wrong?
Alex, Shirley you're about
to raise your hand now.
I keep watching
this hand going--
What do you think?
What could go wrong?
Anything?
We're going to set prices
so that you just earn
a reasonable rate of return.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
what that is.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
You can get it wrong.
We'll set a price.
And we'll let it.
Well, we'll set a price and
let's suppose we adjust it
when we get surprises.
Or let's say, we
are worried about,
and this is what they
did do after a while.
We know that you can't
control your cost of fuel.
That's on the open market.
So we'll pass that
through automatically.
Anything else?
Anything else that could
go wrong if I make sure you
just earn a reasonable
rate of return?
OK, let me not torture
you, think about it.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the variable cost.
They have no incentive
to try to be efficient.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So you would
expect the big problem
would be that the cost would
be too high.
Suppose-- and we can even
sharpen that a little bit.
And that is the main defect
in that form of regulation.
Suppose we recognize
the following.
If I say that a
reasonable rate of return
is below your cost of capital,
then you can't function, right?
If you can't raise money to
invest because you can't earn
enough on it, if I've set
the rate of return too low,
you can't go forward.
So I don't want that to happen.
So I make sure you earn more
than your cost of capital
on the investments.
I have to make sure that
every dollar you invest
earns more than what it costs
you to raise that dollar?
What might that lead
to, just intuitively?
David.
AUDIENCE: Over-investment.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Over-investment,
which they referred to in the
literature as gold plating,
right?
If I have a choice of doing
it with three people or a $5
million investment,
I'll do a $5 million
investment because I'll
earn money on that.
And I won't earn any
money on the three people.
So you have a tendency
you would expect to have
capital investment too high.
There are a couple
other problems,
we've hit two of them.
I'll just mention the others.
When people talk
about this system,
they talk about capture.
Well, I actually gave a talk
at the Massachusetts Commission
a couple of weeks ago.
And it turns out
there's a little office
complex inside South Station.
You don't see it, but you
kind of go around the corner
and you go up and they
have some offices.
Who do you think goes
into those offices?
The companies they regulate.
Who do you think says nice
things to them, talks to them,
has any relationship
with them at all?
The people they regulate.
Who has lots of lawyers
and lots of PR people
to make a lot of noise
if they're unhappy?
The people they regulate.
So a strong model not an
entirely accurate model,
but not an entirely crazy
model is, after a while,
the regulators serve
the folks they regulate.
Because you want
to make them happy.
You see them every day,
they come in your office.
You can imagine a different
kind of relationship
and sometimes you see it.
But one argument is, all the
consumers are not organized.
The utility is.
The electric companies
are organized.
They have the lawyers.
They have their lobbyists.
They're in every day.
They write the stuff.
Those of us who only pay bills
aren't in there every day.
So that's one problem.
The other problem, it's
a more subtle problem is,
who determines who
pays what price?
And the simplest example
is, prices to industry
versus prices to consumers.
Industry takes power
at higher voltages.
So they ought to
pay a lower price.
What's the price difference?
Well, I submit to you
that price difference
is a political decision
as much as it is anything.
And under a regulated
regime, it's
hard to see how it
could be anything else.
OK, so this system
actually worked.
And I'm going to answer
this question just
in the interest of
our leaving today.
This system generated almost
no complaints until the 1970s,
in electric power, despite
all of these well known,
well-documented problems.
And the reason for
that is in electricity,
technical change was very rapid.
Energy costs were pretty stable.
And so the price of
electricity was dropping.
Very often the utility
would come in and ask
for a rate decrease, all right.
If you fixed my price, and
my costs keep dropping,
there comes a point at which
the price is embarrassingly
high above the monopoly price.
I'm going to make
me too much money
to survive political scrutiny.
I'll ask for a lower price.
So an awful lot
of that happened.
That's a great system.
The regulators don't
have to do much.
The utility comes in and says,
may we please lower our price.
We do a big fuss.
We have lawyers.
We write briefs, after a while
we say, yeah, lower your price.
We all go out to lunch.
This is a good system.
It didn't work in
the '70s very well
when fuel costs began to rise.
And the utilities
came in and said, now
let us raise our prices.
And then people began
to say, wait a minute,
your costs are too high.
You are gold plated
blah, blah, blah.
And it began to be nasty.
OK, so let me take
this up to date.
In the 1970s, we deregulated a
lot of things in this economy.
We deregulated airlines.
We deregulated trucking.
We deregulated railroads.
We deregulated the wellhead
price of natural gas.
And most of those worked.
Price of natural gas went up.
But we stopped having shortages.
Airline prices came down.
Trucking prices came down.
Railroad prices came down.
And costs came down.
And electricity
prices were going up.
Fuel costs were going up.
There was excess capacity.
People had to pay
for that capacity.
There became a move to
deregulate electricity.
But I just told you it
was a natural monopoly.
So the first step was
this law that said,
you have to buy from renewables.
And you have to buy from
combined heat and power
co-generation, hexion type
units at avoided cost.
What's avoided cost?
Well, each state got
to determine that.
Big mess, there were no markets.
But an interesting
step, early '80s, and I
will cite myself here because I
do tend to get cited for this.
In the early '80s,
Paul Joskow and I
were working in this area.
And we began to hear from people
in the Reagan administration,
all this other stuff worked.
We deregulated gas and trucking
and airlines, why don't we
just deregulate electricity.
Why don't we just let the market
determine electricity prices?
I have to say, the words
natural monopoly came to mind.
You're not going to have
competition in transmission.
competition in distribution.
But you know you could have
competition in generation.
It's not like there's
only one generating
plant per city or per state.
There are a bunch of them.
So maybe you could.
So we actually wrote a book
called Markets for Power
that people tell me was
influential more outside the US
than in.
But we said well, you could
do it if you were careful.
If you were careful, and you
worried about market power,
and you worried about
the proper rules,
and you worried about a
half a dozen other things,
you could actually
deregulate generation.
Well, it happened.
And I don't claim
credit for this.
It was mostly because the
Thatcher administration
in England needed money.
So they sold the
electric power system.
This was a shock.
It had happened in Chile
a few years earlier,
nobody noticed Chile, besides
they did it in Spanish.
But in England and
Wales, they did it.
They kept the grid, the
transmission system together.
They regulated the
distribution companies,
but they sold the generators.
They sold the generators.
This was pretty exciting stuff.
And it actually
worked, not perfectly.
They had monopoly power problems
in generation in some areas.
They had to make changes.
But it sort of worked.
Other countries
started to follow.
We started to follow.
Suddenly transmission
lines had to be
willing to carry anybody's
power from anybody to anybody
just like trucks do.
The FERC set up, independent
system operators, they
set up a regime where you could
have one entity run the system,
not own it, but run it.
And you could have wholesale
markets for electricity.
Some people did it, and
I'll show you what happened.
Then we had California.
Who's from California?
Was that fun?
That was not fun.
Prices went crazy in
California, around 2000, 2001.
There were blackouts.
There was screaming.
There was political crisis.
There was Enron doing
various interesting things.
There's litigation, which
may now have finished.
I'm not sure about who did
what to whom, reform stopped.
We'll say a little bit about it.
But let me just say
sort of where we are.
So basically nothing's
happened since California
to a first approximation.
But a lot happened
before California.
So there is competition
in generation.
Generators sell into a market.
In England and Wales, it's the
core European Union policy.
All these state owned monopolies
are moving toward markets,
dramatically, dramatically.
And about 2/3 of US consumers
are served by markets.
This is the picture.
The colored areas are roughly--
they change slightly over time--
roughly the boundaries of
organized wholesale markets.
So in New England, I
showed you these day
ahead clearing demands.
And I'll show you some
prices in a little bit.
This part of Texas runs
a very nice market.
California after
a while restarted.
This part of the country
is traditional, vertically
integrated.
We generate.
We transmit.
We distribute.
What's a market utilities.
In the West, the federal
government has a huge presence,
operates a lot of the
transmission system.
There are sort of elements
of market, but not really.
And there's an awful
lot of preference power.
Because there's a lot of
government-owned hydro.
If you go up the Columbia
River, you pass a dam after dam
after dam which you all own.
So New England, one
of the earlier ones,
very nice little market.
These are average
wholesale prices
in New England
for the last year.
The prices are hourly I think.
Maybe they've gone
down to 15 minutes now.
But at least hourly.
They also are
differentiated by region.
If there's a problem
transmitting power from A to B,
the prices in A
and B can differ.
If there is no problem,
they differ trivially.
So again, this is
the day ahead price,
and this is the real time price.
I don't know what happened
last August, or late July,
whether that was a
particularly hot day.
It was clearly anticipated.
You see the blue shot
up as well as the green.
Sometimes the day
ahead is too high.
ahead is too low.
There is a day ahead market.
And then there is
what actually has
to happen to follow the load.
So sometimes the day
ahead market overestimates
demand and thus costs.
Sometimes it underestimates.
But those are daily prices.
I'll show you some
hourly prices on Monday.
And here's what
the US looks like.
No other country
has a system that
is this fragmented and diverse,
with the possible exception
of Japan depending on how
you count fragmentation
and diversity,
since half of Japan
runs on 50 cycles a
second and half of Japan
runs on 60 cycles.
We at least beat that.
So about 2/3 are served
by organized markets.
ISO is Independent
System Operator,
RTO is Regional
Transmission Operator.
Differences are immaterial.
We have a transmission
system owned
by about 450 different entities,
some federal, some local,
some state, some private.
About 2/3 of the system
is owned by private firms.
We have on the order
of 3,200 entities
selling electricity, 3,200
entities selling electricity.
Cooperatives aren't
regulated by anybody.
Investor owned utilities,
which are about 2/3
regulated by states and by feds.
The munis and the
federal systems
are not regulated by anybody.
And that retail
competitors at the bottom
is a development that was
under way before California.
It has gotten stalled
because of California.
But in Texas is where
it's most prevalent.
You can buy electricity
from any one
of a number of competing firms.
It will be delivered by the
monopoly distribution company.
But you will pay for it
to some other firm that's
responsible for making sure
there's enough electricity
to serve its customers.
That's the model in Europe.
It exists in Massachusetts,
but isn't very effective.
Just last week I got
my first solicitation--
this has been 10 years--
to switch suppliers.
And because I believe
in computation, I did.
So there's enough
retail competition
that people who
don't own wires--
plus I thought I'd see
what would happen--
plus people who don't own wires
sold 8% of the electricity
in the country.
I think these are 2010 numbers.
That's a big change.
That was 0.
The bigger change is
on the generation side.
So you have government systems--
and this is a big number, 16%.
Not all federal, some
state, some municipal,
Los Angeles for instance, 16%.
Investor owned utilities
with retail sales,
42%, independent
producers, folks
who have entered the wholesale
market who do not sell directly
to retail customers
42% of generation.
So we have moved
a fairly long way
toward a market based system.
But we're not quite there.